we would like to take this opportunity
to officially welcome you to today's
session emerging Trends in building
decarbonization with Peter Ramsey Peter
Ramsey founder of Point Energy
Innovations stands at the Forefront of
low energy and Net Zero building
Innovation with over 40 years of dis
distinguished experience based in San
Francisco his engineering expertise has
contributed to 50 lead Platinum projects
the highest number by any engineer in
the US renowned nationally and globally
he collaborates with top Tech firms
educational institutions and developers
celebrated for his pioneering
contributions Peter has garnered
accolades such as the renewable energy
innovator of the year and ashay's award
of engineering Excellence a Stamford
lecturer for over a decade he's also the
Visionary behind the Stanford building
decarbonization learning accelerator
which equips academics with leading
decarbonization insights and materials
now I'll turn it over to you Peter great
thank you Annette I'm looking forward to
today's session um I'm going to go
through some of the uh Concepts on
building decarbonization and and uh
will'll welcome your questions at the
end they'll you can put them into the
Q&A window and then we'll go through
those
so um the the thing about building
decarbonization we all know why it's
imperative that we we start focusing on
this um we're seeing a lot of evidence
of climate change some of it's uh
dramatic but I think um some of the
other reasons why decarbonization
matters is that um air quality is
impacted heavily by the use of fossil
fuels um particles uh
nox uh socks all these different things
are part of air pollution that's caused
by the use of fossil fuels um the other
thing to understand is that fossil fuels
do disproportionately impact people of
color black people in the US are 10
times children are 10 times more likely
to get asthma than than white children
most of that has to do with fence line
communities living near fossil fuel uh
processing and and extraction
facilities um I think that the other
thing that's really interesting is that
the cost of our gas infrastructure is is
is increasing rapidly um right now the
spending on maintaining the gas
infrastructure has gone up by
300% um in the last 10 years plus or
minus and um that's just only going to
increase over time most of the gas
infrastructure in the US is uh over 50
years old much of it's 100 years old and
it's going to cost a lot of money to
keep that gas infrastructure going so um
there's a lot of reasons that we should
be talking about decarbonization and I
imagine many of you are part of the
building industry and we do play an
important role uh buildings do account
for roughly
40% of the greenhouse gas emissions
um globally and and the number in the US
is also very similar within that there's
both um the operational side and the
construction side and we'll we'll talk
about those I think the thing that's
exciting and a challenge for all of us
is there's a lot of legislation that's
now um being passed and a lot of
activity that's changing how we think
about buildings um New York City for
example now has their local law 97 for
buildings over 25,000 square feet they
have to meet Energy Efficiency and
greenhouse gas emissions limits and some
of those are going to be um somewhat
strict when we get to
2030 um and in California there's a wide
variety of
legislation um that is getting passed
around this I think you know one of the
more important ones is the SB 100 that
is saying by 2045 the um electricity
100% electricity needs to be carbon free
in California I think it's also
interesting in Texas that um that's a
state with the um largest amount of
renewable energy in the US of 59 gws and
growing rapidly and there's variety of
legislation happening in Texas as
well oh sorry um there's also the a
variety of different things going on at
the federal level but I think that the
most significant is this inflation
reduction act the IRA and um its impact
on uh buildings as well as uh energy
production there are literally uh
billions of go dollars available now for
uh clean energy but there's also a lot
of money that's going to be available
for buildings much of that is in the
residential sector for building Energy
Efficiency and heat pumps um but there's
wide uh there'll be a large amount of
that money will also be impacting the
commercial and Industrial sector um
another interesting um uh act that was
passed that we don't hear about as much
is the defense production act where $500
million has been put aside to fund
domestic manufacturing of heat pumps and
other critical minerals and I think that
that's um going to change the
availability of uh heat pumps very
rapidly and we'll be talking a little
bit about heat pumps today
so when we break down carbon emissions
from buildings there's two areas one is
embodied carbon and we did have a
seminar on that a couple weeks ago where
we dove into embodi carbon and how to
decarbonize the construction of
buildings um the other side and the
larger side is the operational carbon
and that is the carbon emissions that's
associated with using energy in
buildings and there's two ways that we
use energy in buildings one would be
that we burn natural gas at the building
uh primarily for heating different
heating needs space heating water
heating uh laundry um but there's also
cooking so we're g to dive into
operational carbon today but before we
do that I did want to just remind
everybody for those of you who didn't
get to attend the last uh seminar or is
that the the path for embodied
decarbonization that is the embodied
carbon is um you know fairly clear we
can start by reusing existing buildings
and doing renovations instead of
building building new and remembering
that embodied carbon is dominated by
Steel and concrete or cement more uh
directly so reusing buildings is a
really good thing where possible in the
US that's a very doable thing um the
next step is choosing carbon
sequestering M materials where available
um wood is one of those that uh
sequesters CO2 into the the the wood
that will go into the building and now
there's this whole emerging area of mass
Timber buildings and we've worked on a
variety of those and it's seems to be
growing rapidly and then um there's the
option of specifying low carbon
materials and a variety of manufact
ufacturers of everything from cement to
Steel are now offering lowc carbon
materials there's even a steel company
in the US that's now offering what they
say is a carbon- free steel and that is
steel that's made with electricity
that's generated from renewable
sources um and then last but not least
for the remaining embodied carbon that
we can't uh get down to zero we can do
different types of high quality carbon
offsets to um to do that and I I'll give
an example of a project where that was
done on the operational side operational
decarbonization the path is also clear
if anything more clear if we take a
typical building and start by making it
more energy efficient that that's the
first and I I would argue the most
important step and we will talk about
Energy Efficiency today um and then
making that efficient building all
electric and finding electric ways to
generate heat is the primary thing and
that I'll talk about that and then last
but not least is to power that efficient
all electric building with renewable
energy and that can be either onsite or
offsite so I'll give some examples of
that um I you know in this quick time
that we have together I just wanted to
um share with you some of the Energy
Efficiency Blockbusters that um already
made their way into the market um LED
lighting is um by far the most well
known um some estimates have that um
reducing the need for several hundred
power plants globally the introduction
LED lighting that has been super
significant um it it permeates all
different building types um but there's
also uh the variable air volume box
which is a quiet but un and unsung hero
in the um HVAC world and commercial
buildings um before we had constant
volume boxes now we have variable volume
boxes for delivering air um that's a
that's something that has reduced um
heating cooling energy and commercial
buildings by the the heating and cooling
energy by at least
50% um there's low emissivity glazing
which is also a significant loose
reducing building envelope loads and
would argue that the variable speed
Drive is potentially globally equally as
important as LED lighting and not a lot
of people know about that but variable
speed drives impact uh buildings but
also factories and a variety of other
industrial uses so there there are
several and there are other examples of
of uh Blockbusters and the Energy
Efficiency side so if we look at the
ashray standard 90.1 one for building
Energy Efficiency which is a recommended
standard um many states do use it as
their building energy code um when we
started with that standard in the mid
1970s and we we pegged that at a energy
use of relative 100 and we look at the
different versions of Ashley 90.1 over
the years to where we are today and
there's actually a new uh version that
just came out um we're seeing over 50%
reduction in energy consumption and and
this ashray 90.1 is not that hard to
meet um with off off-the-shelf
Technologies today I mean most most
commercial buildings do come very close
to meeting it and it doesn't take a lot
of effort to get um to get over the line
so this is super significant not a lot
of people understand that from the 70s
to where we are today buildings are
using half as much energy per square
foot it's very very big deal um what are
the next generation of Energy Efficiency
Blockbusters um there are are several
but um my feeling is that heat pumps are
really very much at the top of the list
um using AI for energy optimization in
buildings is something that I think
we're going to see a lot of over the
next 10 or 20 years I think building
Control Systems uh be they small or
large are very much uh dumb building
controls or let's call them smart time
clocks but we could do so much more in
buildings to optimize the energy use
induction cooking is going to be very
large I'll talk about that for a minute
uh integrative design where we think
more holistically about the design of
Energy Efficiency in buildings um that
that's going to be very important and it
is something that is growing um personal
comfort in buildings the number one
complain of occupants in commercial
buildings is too hot too cold and I
think that we could do a lot for
improving individual comfort in
buildings and that's where we really
need to get to um to provide a higher
level of comfort because everybody wants
something a little bit different and
there are examples of that that are now
emerging and it's somewhat connected to
using Ai and then low pressure drop
systems uh one of the things that's near
and dear to my heart and I'll I I will
mention that um
briefly so if we put together um all of
the Energy
Efficiency that is State what I like to
call stateof the Shelf easily available
but not commonly used if we start with
the Baseline building and this would be
one that meets the ashray
90.1 standard and put together a more
energy efficient building envelope
better lighting better daylighting
that's part of that improve improve plug
load uh meaning things that we plug in
better computers better
monitors and low friction systems
meaning lower pressure drop ducts and
pumps um and then put in a heat pump we
can get the energy consumption of a
building down relatively easily by you
know 40% plus or minus and um this
building was a that we modeled and and
it we've done it in a wide variety of
climates so this particular one was in
North
Carolina and um that building then we
put on 40% of the roof it was a three or
four story building 40% of the roof we
covered with
photovoltaics and it brought the energy
use down further and met a significant
chunk of the energy needs of the
building and then we covered the
building with 80% 80% of the roof with
uh photovoltaics and that on an annual
basis covered um all of the energy
consumption and then I think the thing
that we're going to start seeing are
batteries um used in building so I think
that batteries are going to be another
um Blockbuster that we're going to see
widely deployed in buildings so um
Energy Efficiency has a huge
potential we move on to building
electrification remember I said that the
steps for the decarbonization are make
the building efficient first and then we
Electrify the building the main
tool that we're going to have in
electrifying buildings is heat pumps and
the beauty of heat pumps is that for a
gas heating system we need to put in
something like 105 or 110 units of gas
to get 100 units of heat out that's a
good 90% efficient boiler um but for a
heat pump we can put 33 units of
electricity in to get 100 units of
heating out and that's because heat
pumps are able to pull heat from outside
air and turn and and change the
temperature and deliver that as heat and
the waste product of heat pumps for some
buildings is actually beneficial that is
it's cooling and so you can imagine a
building where in the summer we're
trying to make hot water or things like
showers or a laundry and our waste
products is cooling so we we're working
on buildings where and in Stanford
central plant actually has a system
where when they need cooling they they
when they need heating they capture the
cooling and use that and vice versa when
they need cooling they capture the Heat
and use that if there's a simultaneous
uh use so heat pumps are very efficient
and can provide a lot of benefits that
gas uh boilers can't
provide um so the forecasts for heat
pumps are that there's going to be a
very rapid growth in the use of heat
pumps um this is already happening uh
it's happening very rapidly right now in
Europe because they're transition away
from natural gas for obvious reasons but
we're seeing a similar pickup in the use
of heat pumps in the US and and we we
heat pumps are not brand new they've
been around for quite some time combined
heat pump air conditioner for
residential use has been around for
decades now and I've seen that on houses
all over the US it's white L used and
that is a nice thing is that you can get
one piece of equipment that can provide
both Heating and Cooling so heat pumps
are going to be a significant part of
our future um when we're talking about
electrifying cooking um gas cooking we
are all very familiar with that and
electric resistance cooking has been
around for decades um we don't most
people don't like electric resistance
cooking for a wide variety of reasons um
but electric induction cooking is where
what we're we're going to see um that
when we start moving to electric cooking
and electric induction uses magnetic
field instead of heating a coil and the
magnetic field heat field heats the pot
only and not the surface and it's very
rapid it boils water faster than most
gas stoves and then it's also very
precise in in um going up and down so
electric induction is going to catch on
and um we're seeing that starting to
happen um one of the things about gas
cooking that's coming out now um is that
the indoor air pollution from gas
cooking is significant a recent uh study
by Stanford in addition to other indoor
air pollutants that are caused by using
natural gas um they found that Benzene
concentration of gas St is is um pretty
bad in kitchens and and this is actually
just came out um earlier this year um
was a fairly significant finding they
did a wide variety of tests on that so
it's interesting we as we start to
Electrify homes and this is um sort of
looking into the Future Part of you know
what we're doing at Stanford is trying
to see how these things are going to
go um we are anticipating that you know
some homes will become electrified and
others will still be using gas and and
really the worst case scenario is if a
house is electrified and the last thing
to have is a gas stove so we have to
maintain the gas infrastructure the
utility does for very small use of gas
and and what will happen is gas will
start to become very expensive because
the infrastructure is the same but the
use has gone down and so there is this
idea of targeted electrification if we
can get a whole
neighborhood and this is where utilities
would Target programs the whole
neighborhood to Electrify then in that
neighborhood they can abandon the gas
infrastructure and save all the money of
maintaining that system so this is
looking into the future this is not
something that's happening next year but
if you if you play this out over the
next few decades this is the kind of
thing that we'll need to um start
thinking
about
simultaneously um the cost of Renewables
and the adoption of Renewables um um
especially photovoltaics have been just
accelerating and and you might or might
not be aware but in the US over the last
few
years of the new generation capacity
that was added in the US 75 80% of that
was Renewables solar and wind and solar
is the the bulk of that um similarly
battery storage is growing globally is
growing very rapidly anticipated to
continue to do so batteries being a
really important part of uh having a
high percentage of solar on the grid and
we're going to see batteries at the
utility scale as well as at buildings
and and utility rates are going to start
to change to be um very time time of use
types of rates so that the cost is more
is higher during the periods when the
sun is not available and so batteries
are going to become more and more
economical in several States those kind
of rates have already been implemented
and they're making batteries very coste
effective so um another thing to be
aware of on this you know move towards
Renewables is 22 states have already put
in place uh commitments usually laws at
the state level saying that the grid
needs to be 100% carbon free um by 2050
or sooner as I mentioned California has
a
2045 so um there's a lot going on and I
just wanted to share with you a couple
different examples of these types of
buildings um the RMI Innovation Center
is one that's in Basalt Colorado so it's
it's a cold climate um gets very cold in
the winter lots of snow but it's also
sunny and so they uh RMI spent some time
thinking about this building how can
they make it a super efficient building
and RMI is a a nonprofit organization
that works in um the space of of
decarbonization have been doing that for
many years and so they they started
thinking okay we're going to put in
really good windows and these are um
super windows that have very high
insulating qualities they're going to
get a lot of daylight into the space you
can see it here and they even have this
is the south side of the building you
set up the building so that um when the
sun comes in it hits the floor and heats
up the floor in the winter months um but
does not shine directly on the desk so
they don't have the desks right up at
the window so they get the daylight they
get the the passive solar gain and um
they get a highly insulated building at
the same time they even have chairs that
provide individual Comfort through
Heating and Cooling Heating and then fan
ventilation on the chair so that people
can get to the Comfort that they want um
the interesting thing about that and
they also insulated the building
envelope the non- glass parts of the
envelope very highly is that it allowed
them to eliminate the expense they were
going to put in initially the idea was
to put in a big ground Source heat pump
system heat pump all electric right nice
system but very expensive but instead of
buying the system the expensive ground
Source system they put more and more
money into the building envelope so they
got to the point that that wasn't needed
and so all they needed was a heat
recovery ventilator and
six equivalent of six hair dryers of
electric heating so they put some small
electric baseboards this a 15,000 foot
building so that's a very small amount
of heat so is it's not a heat pump but
it was so little of it that it made
sense so this is integrative design
overall the building costs less than
what it would have cost if they put in
the heat
pump so another project that I'm working
on currently and it's under construction
is the American Institute of
Architects headquarters in Washington DC
and this is a few blocks away from the
White House it's a building that was
built in the
70s and um
in that time at that time uh building
installation and and good quality
Windows was not a thing and also heating
and cooling systems were not done in a
way that was that's very energy
efficient so um what they're going to do
is they're going to replace the lighting
put in LED lighting instead of
inefficient older fluorescent lighting
and better lighting fixtures and they're
going to set the building up for better
daylighting instead of really dark glass
are going to put in a lighter glass that
transmits more of the daylight um they
are going to put in a new glazing double
glazing low emissivity glazing that lets
the light in but blocks the heat out in
the summer months and they are going to
Electrify the building so they're going
to take the natural gas boilers that
make Steam and they're going to uh
abandon those take them out of the
building and then they're going to uh
put heat pumps on the roof to make the
hot water and it it's interesting
because
with the reduction of the load from the
uh electri from the lighting system and
the oversizing of the building even
though they're adding all this new
electric load in the key pumps they
don't need to upssize the electric
service to the
building so um they are going to put
some solar photovoltaics on the roof
this is a seven story building and
that's only going to amount to about 10%
of the annual use of the building so
what they're going to do is they are
going to purchase off-site renewably
generated electricity through this Pepco
DC power connect program and with the
power connect program you can select
your generation
provider and there's a few options for
Generation providers that have 100%
renewable It's a combination of wind and
solar and the one that they're using is
called clean Choice energy and so um
they will be purchasing at least the
part of their bill that goes to
generation will be going to renewable
energy so they have on-site 10% offsite
90% renewable energy electricity for now
an all electric
building um interesting thing is about
the embodied carbon of this building
reusing the building instead of excuse
me instead of building a new
building is saving
76% of the Ed carbon so they they just
avoiding that embodied carbon by reusing
building so you can see that's the
biggest step but the next step that
they're taking to offset the remaining
embodied carbon and it has a lot to do
with the windows that they're purchasing
Furniture carpet all the stuff that's
going inside the building and there's
some there is some steel structural
upgrades and things like that um so what
they're doing for that is they have
purchased solar
panels and those have been donated to
Habitat for Humanity who's going to be
installing those solar panels on lwi
income homes in DC and Northern Virginia
and those panels are going to avoid
electricity consumption from the average
grid that does have um coal and natural
gas in it and that will avoid carbon
that's equivalent to the number of
panels that they bought is going to
avoid carbon from Electric that's
equivalent to the embod carbon of the
new materials that they're bringing to
the site so I think that's a very
creative way of doing an offset
obviously you can you don't have to be
um do it in such a uh deliberate way
there's there's offsets that you can buy
where people are grouping them together
and it's important to get high quality
offsets I'd say that this kind of offset
is as high quality as you can get um
I've worked a lot with a company in
India called emphasis and they are
collaborators with Stanford and they
have 30 million square feet of offices
throughout the country and 250,000
employees so it's quite a large um
footprint as far as buildings and they
embarked uh about 10 years ago on a
program to um make much more efficient
buildings and then to go back to their
existing buildings and retrofit them
overall over that period they've reduced
their electricity consumption per
employee by 55% I think it's probably
the largest corporate Energy Efficiency
program that's ever happened and I think
it's important to note that large Energy
Efficiency improvements are uh possible
in buildings and um one of my colleagues
at Stanford Jim Sweeney uh did write a
book and it was based on on um research
he did with his um graduate students and
postdocs over a five-year period they
looked at energy consumption in the US
all sectors and said um based on the
efficiency that was available at the
time um in the earlier periods in the
70s when the oil crisis happened and
then compare that to where we are today
so how much fuel is consumed on an
airplane per passenger mile over time um
what about industrial production how
much energy embodied energy is in a car
or they looked at building so they they
looked at a wide variety of sectors in
the US and what they found was Energy
Efficiency over the period from mid 70s
until um 2015 had provided more energy
reduction than all of the new energy
sources domestic ones combined and that
um they they were looking at nuclear
power Renewables all these
things were small compared to the gains
from Energy Efficiency so you know for
that reason I am very much a proponent
um of decarbonization that's going to
happen with Energy
Efficiency so I'm going to wrap up now
so we can have some discussion um the
key takeaways from this is that
decarbonization is emerging rapidly for
most clients in most markets and I I'd
say some of it's being driven by
legislation and
such but some of some of it's just being
driven by you know what the clients want
and then ultimately Energy Efficiency
makes economic
sense so there's a wide variety of
reasons that that people are moving this
direction heat pumps are rapidly
evolving as the demand for them uh
surges and I um as a person who works in
the design of buildings um where for
commercial systems three or four years
ago there was maybe three viable options
in each category on commercial building
heat pumps now I'm seeing today that
number be closer to 10 and I'm seeing a
lot of people are calling me and saying
look we've got some new stuff coming out
and I think that that that number will
be more like 15 or by 20 30 more like 20
plus options in each category the the um
I think one of the more telling things
was when I was at the National
Conference for building um uh heating
cooling systems ashray conference the
one of the oldest boiler companies in
America in their display had a huge
display at right at the center of of
their booth at that show with a heat
pump it's their first heat pump so that
was I I um encouraging and
significant um I think low carbon
building materials are emerging quickly
uh not only are commercial providers
there we're seeing a lot of research at
universities on things like low carbon
and zero carbon concrete and carbon
sequestering concrete and cement um
primarily and um we're seeing a lot of
research going to that and we're also
seeing Venture Capital money going in
that Direction um Energy Efficiency
remains key element of
decarbonization and then U most carbon
free electricity will be generated
offside I do get this question a lot is
do we have to put solar panels on every
building is that how we're going to get
there I think at the end of the day
solar um and wind the majority of it
will be generated offsite at utility
scale because it's more affordable that
way we are going to continue to see a
lot of solar go on buildings because at
the end of the day we can generate
electricity on buildings on the roof of
buildings usually in most areas in the
US cheaper than we than buying it and so
solar is going to continue to be
attractive on buildings but I think the
the majority of Renewables are going to
be generated offsite and that's how
we're going to be able to decarbonize
the operation of buildings thank you
thank you Peter for such an interesting
and insightful presentation um uh now
we're going to um move over to the Q&A
so I encourage everyone to submit their
questions in the Box on your console um
labeled Q&A um now let's get into some
of these questions um the first one um
is from George uh carbon offsets have
been Justified
criticized from obfuscation
inadequacy imper impermanence any
comments yeah I I I totally agree and
that's why um high quality offsets are
are the high quality is the important
part of it and I you know I think what
what people are saying is you know we
could plant some trees as an offset but
what if those trees five years later or
10 years later get cut down right and
then that offset is not an offset and
actually could become a liability if
that's um you know composting and
creating methane so I really would um
urge you to spend some time if you are
going to go in the direction of offsets
uh for the embodied carbon in building
the the bit that's unavoidable to really
spend some time uh finding finding out
you know what is the quality offset and
I I've been to a couple conferences
where there's a lot of discussion about
that some are saying that the only
quality offset that they can really
count on is carbon removal and that's
where carbon CO2 is taken out of the air
um that is so energy intensive there are
questions about whether or not carbon
removal is actually a valid way to go so
you know that's why when we're working
with the a AIA we we said let's do
something that we know it's really G to
make a difference here and that's what
the the solar panel solution came up so
I
um um we could have a whole discussion
about uh uh offsets and and how to go
about that but I do think there there is
some validity to it but caution needs to
be
used thanks Peter um I'll move us over
to the next question from Aaron I
believe that on-site Renewables is more
efficient has less impact on the grid
and there are incentives for moving
forward with this but our capitalist
Society is penalizing this approach more
centralized energy generation is growing
at a faster Pace what is your opinion on
this topic and do you think we should
provide stronger incentives for more
distributed generation yeah well you
know there is a debate about U you know
on-site versus offsite um there's a lot
of advantages of distributed energy
generation and that what I'm saying is
onsite and and um it gives a resilience
to the grid a lot of the if there's
constraints on a grid um that is points
and as we Electrify this this is going
to be a little bit of an issue there are
points in the electrical grid that are
going to become pinch points and you
know a lot of people are saying that the
one of the major barriers to to you know
full adoption of Renewables is the power
lines um that are going to need to be
built and we need to build a lot of them
to get power lines from where we can
generate if we do it centrally to where
uh cities are and so that would say
distributed is much better because we
don't need to build new power lines when
we have the distributed that is solar on
roofs of buildings um there are still a
good number of incentives but the the
thing that's really a disincentive is
the net metering that occurs so each
state has a different net metering
solution um in California there was
recently a a roll back of the um net
metering so it's not as positive for
people to have their own on-site
generation there are certain states
where um it's just there they basically
net metering is not um not even
available um because the for a variety
of reasons the utilities don't want to
see that now um I don't think it's
possible to stop uh remote or or on-site
Renewables because once we comb even if
net metering is really bad um there's no
place that's banned the use of solar so
you could have solar with battery and
not feed electricity back into the grid
and and get a large percentage of your
electricity generated onsite you
probably in most locations will still
need some off-site electricity so anyway
I am a proponent of on-site solar but I
do think that there um the solution is
going to be a hybrid of on-site and
offsite um so i' you know I'd leave it
at that but again it is it is an
important discussion to have and each
state is sort of coming up with a
different set of
solutions thanks Peter um okay so the
next one what do you see as the greatest
barrier to building the carbonization at
this
moment that's a I like that question
because um it's something that I think
about a lot and I you know I think that
um
five or 10 years ago we could say that a
lot of the technology is not there um I
think now the technology is there I
think cost is still a barrier as we're
still you know figuring out how do we
make this cost effective once people
start doing it Americans are really good
at figuring out how to make stuff cost
effective and that's something that the
world envies about what we do you know
is that we really have this Ingenuity
around figuring out how to make things
affordable so um I think we're in that
period now and there I'm seeing lots of
solutions that are making um
electrification and Energy Efficiency
very affordable I think that the next
thing that's
there
is um people's understanding of you know
is it possible do we want to do this are
there risks that we don't understand I'm
I'm Consulting with a large company and
and uh they have the money and the uh uh
the leadership at the company is on
board um with um using solar and getting
more Energy Efficiency out of their
buildings but what we're seeing is that
the facilities managers are now becoming
a barrier now they're not being mean or
dumb nothing like that but they're just
saying look you know if I spend the time
in
to put solar on the roof of this
building or change out the lighting or
the chiller I'll save energy that would
be good and the money's got the company
but I'm not I'm taking risk like if I
put in a new heating or cooling system
it it could break it's like a new thing
and it it could break one guy said well
if I put solar on the roof and you know
there's a hurricane and and water leaks
through the roof then I could lose my
job for that but if he does the Sol or
he's not going to you know get any
additional job security or bonus or
anything there's not incentives for the
middle management people to do the right
thing so I I really do feel that um
there's perceived risks and and people's
um people's approach to this is is is an
important barrier and there's actually
um a group at Stanford Business School
that's studying what are what are the
incentives that are needed at the
leadership level within companies to get
companies to change how they approach
their carbon footprint or their energy
consumption these kind of things and so
I I I do feel that it's more than
technology it's more than cost there's a
human element here and I think we should
all be thinking about how do we
incentivize and
celebrate um the people who accomplish
these things and what we're recommending
to this company that I'm Consulting with
is financi IAL incentives for mid-level
Management Facility management people
that do the right thing and a modest
incentive that could be a very small
fraction of the cost of an overall
project of putting in a new Chiller or a
heat pump or solar um a small fraction
of that cost can go to a financial
incentive to the Phil Facilities
Management person that would in many
times be the barrier that we need to
overcome wow yeah I mean I think
incentive is huge so
yeah how do we crack crack that
nut um okay so our next question here um
is on one of our key takeaways actually
um are there heat pump varieties which
can replace portable window-based AC
units can they be cheap enough to be
used by lowincome
people yeah there are um window unit
heat pumps air conditioners combined
units and there's also um the through
thewall units that they use in hotels
lower cost hotels those are also
available in heat pump air conditioners
so it's the same compressor but it's in
a rever reversing mode right so it uses
the compressor to make cold air in the
summer and then that same compressor
it's got a reversing valve it it works
to Pro prod provide heat in the
wintertime so they are available um they
are more expensive than a cooling only
window unit but it's not anything like
double it's like 20 or 30% higher so yes
that is available even for affordable
housing and low
income thank you uh moving on to the
next one from ano can we get some more
information from the Colorado renewable
project that you
mentioned yeah so RMI uh the RMI
Innovation Center you can Google it they
they they've written several reports
about the building because they really
do want to celebrate it um their website
is ri.org that's the name of the
organization RMI and if you Google the
RMI Innovation Center building and it's
in Basalt Colorado which is right next
to Aspen um you'll find some reports on
that um it should be fairly easy if
you're having trouble just contact me
and I'll I'll help direct
you thanks Peter um next one has
education and building decarbonization
expanded so that future Building Systems
have knowledgeable designers engineers
and
Architects yeah um our Stanford building
decarbonization learning accelerator is
specifically addressing that issue I
think that um the next generation of
Architects engineers and construction
managers need to understand this
information the thing that I've and I've
been teaching a class at Stanford on
this topic for 15 years now and um my
class size is double in the last few
years the students now get it that hey
there climate change is there they've
known that for a while and there there's
a lot of things about stress around
climate and everything but what students
are starting to realize is that there's
a variety of solutions and they want to
understand what are those Solutions so
we are seeing a rapid growth in interest
in this
area but it's still you know it's still
early several of the universities that
we're working with and providing
teaching materials and you can also go
to our website and and look at the
teaching materials at bd. stanford.edu
um those teaching materials are sever of
the universities that we're talking to
are saying well we've got a program in
talking about Building Systems or
architecture or whatever and we want to
start layering in decarbonization the
the professors are saying yeah I'm
hearing that more and more what is that
can you help me out and so I think that
the the next gener the the courses that
are going to teach next generation are
in a sense being built out right now so
that within um my estimation is that
within the next five years we're going
to see most major a programs teaching uh
and talking about decarbonization in one
form or
another great um your bdla um Center is
doing great work so thanks Peter
um next question can you expand more on
the profile of a mixed fuel house versus
an all electric house from renewable
energy
sources yeah um
so mixed fuel houses are the majority of
houses in
America um that is where we've got both
Gas and Electric available and um you
know I think that the decarbonization of
existing houses is going to take you
know it's a multi-decade project um
first I think it makes a lot of sense in
new construction if we're building a
Housing Development or new construction
remodels it's easy to say let's just do
electric and some cities around the
country are now starting to implement um
building codes that are saying that new
construction has to be
electric it's interesting because in the
southeast of the us and that is the you
know Southern States
um the penetration of electric heating
is already very high the the number
somewhere in the 70s 70% of homes are
already using electric heating of one
form or another some of it's electric
resistance but a lot of it's also heat
pumps and same thing with electric
cooking they they have the older
electric resistance cooking not as good
as induction um but induction will start
to you know take take over that market
as well so there's a wide
a large part of the a large part of the
us where 100% electric homes is already
a reality like a high percentage of them
and so I think when we're talking about
this we need to remember it's not like a
weird new thing this is something that's
been around for a while and if we just
layer on more efficient homes with
simple
Technologies and the um you know current
state of the shelf of things like heat
pump
induction cooking we're going to get
homes that are um efficient but also
provide really good Services people
don't generally homeowners don't care a
lot about um you know all these things
decarbonization all but they they really
do care a lot about comfort and
well-being in a home so you know the
when we have a new
stove if the induction stove provides
better service that's what's going to
make people happy and feel like okay
this is the right thing I think what
we're going to find with new heat pump
air conditioners is that they provide
better service the with the controls it
can provide better Heating and Cooling
it's more
precise um you know it delivers it at
the time when they want it and then it's
done in a way that's more reliable
because they have just a you know single
piece of equipment they're not owning a
furnace and air conditioner and all this
other stuff that they have to maintain
along with that so yeah I do think that
um this all electric um is going to be
the way things move and the hybrid house
you know the combined fuel is going to
be
solely um something that's not
interesting and and part of what will
drive it and what I was trying to say is
the cost of gas will get more and more
expensive and so that it's going to be
less and less attractive to people to
have the hybrid house yeah that makes
sense uh um everything is already very
expensive so cutting costs on some gas
would be nice um okay so next question
um how will Society handle risk of
relying on one energy source like
electricity for example in the future if
outages happen at the transmission level
only those with backup energy storage
can have power availability but on the
worst days such as when there are
several days of rain this could be a
risk for even those who have solar
battery do you do you see hydrogen
having more
role yeah
um so uh you know there's a lot there as
far as reliability the grid and those
kind of things I think that you know the
reliability question of electricity and
I I live in California we're very
familiar with power outages because
we've had these we didn't have them this
year because the Fire season was you
know basically non-existent because we
had good rain last year and snow
but the subsequent years we had for
several years fires and the electric
company would turn off the power grid
and certain areas to um avoid those
wires um you know coming in contact with
trees and starting new fires right
so um there are some questions about the
grid and and reliability so the the
thing to understand about gas appliances
is that for safety reasons all of the
Modern Gas Gas Appliances not the old
ones but the new ones require
electricity to
operate we're not going to you know a
gas furnace doesn't work without
electricity sorry gas stoves um the the
newer ones that are like 15 years and
less require electricity um they have
inter loocks so that you can't use the
gas when electricity is not available so
you know there's a there's uh gas is
also
vulnerable uh
this vulnerability can be
offset the electric vulnerability with
storage as the questioner uh mentioned
um and that storage will be available
not only at the utility level but also
in a distributed way so I think we're
going to see more and more storage and
then solar distributed another reason
why distributed solar is a good thing
so um I think that that's there there's
ways that we can make the electric grid
more reliable
and um that's fairly obvious as far as
hydrogen is concerned we will see a lot
of hydrogen in the
future there there's no doubt that
hydrogen will be critical in industrial
processes there's a lot of industrial
processes that just need heat and we
can't get exactly what we need with
electricity and it will be more
affordable to do with hydrogen that's
generated with Renewable Power so a wide
variety of um Technologies are being
being investigated uh in industrial
processes where hydrogen becomes the key
thing there's a lot of discussion about
using hydrogen in longdistance um
Trucking for example is another area and
there is discussion about using hydrogen
in homes and there's been different U
research projects on that and tests of
that um a lot of people are saying that
that's going to be a tough sell in homes
as compared to electricity we can't use
existing gas pipes with 100% hydrogen
you can use 10% hydrogen but if you get
above that the hydrogen starts to Decay
existing piping that we use the steel
pipes and the different PVC pipes that
we use for gas don't work with hydrogen
you have to have a new pipe material so
putting in a new hydrogen infrastructure
is probably going to be more in most
areas for homes is going to be more
expensive than and um just electrifying
so um hydrogen's part of our I'm sorry
hold on hydrogen is part of our future
but the the jury is out on how big of a
role it will play
yeah okay thank you um we have time for
just about one last question um so I
will um go with the next one which is I
am curious to know what the role of
Structural Engineers is in the road to
building decarbonization and at
zero well I I think Structural Engineers
are critical on the embodied carbon side
of things there's you know the
structural system in buildings is the
number one thing for embodied carbon so
steel and cement that's eventually
concrete those two things are are um
depends on the building type and
everything but um they can up make up
75% of the embodied carbon so
um in this discussion about
decarbonization Structural Engineers are
becoming front and center now if we take
a building where it's efficient it's
electrified it's connected to renewable
energy that's pretty easy to do in a lot
of areas in the US today it's not a hard
thing but what's left is the embodied
carbon so there's lots of buildings that
I'm working on that they're like well
thank you Peter now we've got a problem
with the embodied carbon it was always a
problem but now it's a a bigger percent
of the the carbon footprint of the
building and so structal Engineers are
becoming a very important part of that
discussion so I'd urge you to um start
digging in and looking at um
alternatives to um steel and concrete
structures Mass Timber and such but then
within the steel and cement categories
there's a wide variety of options that
are lower car carbon and starting to
learn about those and you know some of
those have already been available and
are widely used things like fly ash and
cement and such so yeah great all right
well Peter thanks again for this
interesting and insightful conversation
and for answering all of the questions
that we had time for um to everyone in
the audience with us live today thank
you for all your questions and
participation as well I want to remind
you that today's session um was recorded
and a link to this will be made
available to all of you within a week um
so look forward to that email in your
inbox um and have a great rest of your
day hope you all enjoyed our session
today thank you thank
you